this is a production of Cornell
University
and we want to make sure that that data
is available
to commute you know to these breeders
and research communities also folks that
are engaged in in Industry developing
new technologies like Kemp Crete and I
mean we've heard some really cool
applications for hemp material fiber
different kind of fibrous geofabrics
it's incredible where this where this
crop can go and so we we feel very
privileged to be part of the community
and to support support these efforts
where we can my specific title is
research geneticist currently I think
you know where we can really focus our
efforts is as Zach mentioned these
multi-state evaluation efforts and so we
have a couple great collaborators here
Stephen belush
Ernie Siebert uh from Alabama and Oregon
State and also Larry smart and Chris
smart from Cornell
um really appreciate uh and
oh yeah yeah and uh so new from uh from
Alabama a m as well also many other
great collaborators Shelby Ellison here
uh David suchoff a great research
community and hopefully everyone's able
to kind of reach out and chat with some
of these researchers
um so I think evaluations of this
material across States because some
material might do very well in New York
but perform poorly in Oregon City or
Alabama and vice versa there might be
some material that looks horrible in New
York but looks great in Alabama for
Growers uh in the in that Southeast
region
um so I think that characterization is
is so vitally important of this
germplasm it's coming back skating you
know accessions every day um sometimes
hundreds of accessions will come in in a
lot and so it's a big uh big task to do
a thorough evaluation we're trying as as
hard as we can and to grow out these
materials and evaluate for many
different traits including fiber quality
grain quality and the one that is
probably most pressing is secondary
metabolites looking at THC levels and
then as as a
as a geneticist I'm curious
what which of these germplasm accession
which is this germplasm has stable and
low THC levels across across these
different states so that we can use
those varieties for back Crossing into
this diverse term plasm so that we can
have regulatory compliant material
that's available for distribution
and so I also want to highlight another
study that we're doing with Chris smart
and Larry's group and Nicole goche and
Bob Pierce down at the University of
Kentucky and that is looking at
resistance to a bunch of really
important pathogens that includes
powdery mildew septoria downy mildew and
fusarium petite and so we think that
that's going to be a really important
data to get out to growers in the
research and Industry communities as
well if there are other traits that we
that we haven't mentioned that you think
would be really important I know that
there is an earlier question about
looking at stem
THC concentration that I think we're
we're open and willing to discuss
um looking at additional traits uh this
year we started a root study as well
because some folks mentioned that Roots
were very important and looking at like
root biomass root morphology
and so your comments help inform where
our research goes and what kind of data
gets posted onto Grant Global so we're
very excited about this very excited to
tell folks what we're up to I don't
think our our trials are going to be
part of today's activities but if you'd
like to see them at some point reach out
to us and we can take you on a tour of
that of our research trials just a
little bit a couple miles away from here
um and I want to thank Larry and the
Cornell team for for hosting this event
and um and please reach out with
questions at any time and good seeing
this group all right thank you
first nationally in fiber production or
sustainable construction materials
there is a lot of interest in Chinese uh
hemp coming in from China
which grows very well grows very tall
flowers very late
so it's good for fiber production
but
every Chinese cultivar or variety I call
them land races
that we have tested has tested hot
we know the genetics of THC production
we know why they test hot
because the genes for THC production
have not been bred out of those Chinese
varieties
we have done that in our breeding
program and Louise is going to talk
about those lines as well as all the
varieties that you see here that he is
evaluating
uh I think we if we can if you can think
about how we can get people moving down
to our next stop which is down by the
farm Droid there then we'll get get our
blood flowing here a little bit chilly
but Luis has uh about 40 minutes to
describe all of this stuff here well 30
minutes plus questions
thanks so much Larry uh first of all I'd
like to pass on some samples for you
guys to see
so those are the generics or the seeds
that we are uh we have currently our
general classroom collection uh you can
see different seat sizes and what
happens when you extract uh The Hemp
Hearts from it and then you get the
hearts and the holes you can also see
pressed oil and you will see this Gunk
at the bottom is because it was whole
seed press oil it was it wasn't just the
it wasn't just the heart sorry
um so just pass around so people can
take a look at those
um but yeah so today I want to cover a
small flow trial which encompasses 12
fiber cultivars you can see on my right
and 18 dual purpose cultivars in total
we have a 26 cultivar some of them are
trialled in both dual and fiber to see
which protein system works best for them
um so first of all I started my third
last year with this question who here is
wearing or having any fire derived
product
thank you so much
thank you
um so yeah I here I think I'm very
confident that most of you know what
Empire is where it comes from and
everything but just a quick reminder so
make sure that we're on the same page it
comes from the outer the cortex which is
like the bus called bust
um and then the inner the inner Woody
part also called The Herd is what is
used for uh hemp crate or pull for paper
um you can use with animal padding right
so to make sure that we're all on the
same page right so I don't wanna
tell you like how to grow Fiverr
specifically or like the anatomy or the
physiology of hemp I think you some of
you already know more or less what that
is but rather I would like to tell you
the importance of what we're doing right
now and with that I think the best
start from the very beginning
uh in 1912 Mr Dewey was the first well
this is claimed to be the first hemp
reader uh he started working in around
Minnesota Kentucky and those cultivars
were named based on like the origin of
the ocean so there's kimmington Kentucky
Minnesota Washington
jimington China or Chinta or something
like that China Washington and it's
Fairington which is a Italian land race
and a Washington originated population
so you can tell
the assessment of ham General classroom
has happened long time ago goes way back
and he already evaluated multiple
aeroplasm for different Origins so you
can tell that what we're doing is not
nothing new but rather necessary
so later in 1925 despite the prohibition
that happened in the U.S that doesn't
mean that hemp reading is stopped he
carry on in Germany is a researcher
called Gustav breadman he worked on
improving past content and it was very
interesting reading this paper because
in Germany I had to translate a little
bit so hopefully I'm conveying the
information
um he was able to prove this past
content that I was talking about from
nine percent to 30 so we're talking
about 2.5 to 3 full increase in bass
content at the same time all the
researchers were able to find the first
monishes uh individuals in 1930s
so it was very interesting so then
they're going to do stuff private
Brotherman uh had a successor and he in
his paper in 1952 suggested or indicated
that this professor will use these first
one initial cultivars and combine them
with this highly
high quality cultivars that Dr releman
developed so you can see how the hand
breathing has been going on and what you
are seeing right now may have been
originated from a long time ago but from
those researchers
um later in 1946
Walter Hoffman another German researcher
identified what he called bright stems
mutation which is a yellow stem that you
may see on that side
um so eventually
um the need of ease of the collaboration
um in the industry
elicited the Dutch researchers to
release four cultivars among which there
is this called chameleon in Ivory which
are well researched yellow stem cultures
and there are papers from 2018 very
recently and from this year that
suggests the ease of the corrugation the
higher bus content compared to a green
stem
so I think as you can see like what we
are doing is not new but rather
necessary and is where we are right now
and is a guy where we should go
um so bringing it back to us to us as a
summary uh
there was a first a first breeder in the
U.S using some recurrent penalty pixel
action
um there were some researchers in
Germany improving bus content others
finding personal issues others finding
price stamps so let's bring it
to current call in time
uh right now the vast content that we
see is about 25
35 bus content however this year I read
a paper claiming firmlythuania claiming
a culture having 42.23 bus which is
ridiculous
um so it's great right like hopefully
it's true I don't know but
that you know these cultures are all
over the place I just mentioned
Lithuania right so we need to assess
hero classes for different locations to
see what performs best thing if it
doesn't what traits can we take
advantage of so that it works here with
other General customers more adapted to
here right
um
so
yeah
um so for that reason you have young
Blossom here that is the issue there is
one issue that is yellow that is thin
stem the stick stamp
um and then we have dual purpose here so
does any of you know the current or the
average yield in the U.S or fiber or
grain
well I didn't know that either so yeah
every single day
um
yeah so in Canada it's about a thousand
kilograms per hectare so being a path to
the system you may understand is 750 190
pounds per acre in like average with dry
lands and irrigated they have two
different
um so for Fiverr uh in a fiber
production system alone instead of dual
is 2.4 to 4.8 tones very good breaker
and for dual is 0.3 to 0.6 don't break
why am I telling you all this number
because you have handouts of our yield
our projected yield for these local
trials and what we can achieve if we
extend this on a small trial to a larger
scale
so I wanted you to have that those
numbers as a reference when you look
into those handouts
um
[Applause]
and lastly another thing I wanted to say
is well
hemp produces fiber right but there's
another problem which is fiber it's
widely grounded right a paper in 2020
assets the comparison between hand fiber
and cotton
and forever on average produces three
times more fiber per acre than over area
actually than cotton is more
environmentally friendly and
um it reduces costs in Agricultural
Product approach or cultural activities
rather of
77.7 percent
so the numbers are out there and the
potential is out there you need to take
advantage of it
and this is what we're doing right now
so here we have 12 fiber cultures uh you
can see the names I mean you also have
the handouts so you can freely walk
around and look at the plants if you
don't like this reps
um
we have
four reps in a randomized complete block
design each rep is a block with all the
YouTubers are randomized within the
block of those four blocks
um so I spoke a lot so let me just pause
a little any questions so far
great question
um
so it will vary because of germination
rate seed size so I don't like cookie
curved numbers because you may not have
specific Target plan density that you
need so
um so that the what I can tell you is
the idea of plant density of the target
plant density
uh or Dual Purpose that would be 12 tons
per square meter and for fiber per
square foot first workout sorry
um and for fiber it would be infinite
from like 30 plants per square
foot
so
I think you should go by the Target plan
density and then just based on
germination inside yep I'm curious what
you did for weed control and how these
plots were prepared if you did no more
flour just harrowing did you do any
cover crop testing any regenerative
farming
chemicals any manual cultivation was
it's done in all the we didn't spray
any other side at all I don't think we
had a cover crop here before I don't
remember
um
watering
did you water it rain fast
yeah it's not watering I think just the
very beginning we oh no no no irrigation
yeah and then there's regular
mechanization around the edges but
you know
so which is a very good point that you
bring up because based on the genetics
we have different Leaf sizes right so
that can create kind of because you're
very early in the system preventing any
Wheat growth so that's another trait
that we're interested in uh what I would
like to say it's like the ceiling bigger
like how bigger is a plant burial in the
system to reach that kind of enclosure
so then you don't have any competition
you have one color will unrelated
if you've been tracking or testing
content it's very interesting yeah so at
Harvest we collect we Harvest one square
meter and then that square meter
composes all the stems there and then we
have we will we will lay the red
material and after that we will milk
mail the material and analyze a cellular
hemicellulose and effective content last
question
do you call the hurt the shifts do you
call that fiber I don't refer to itself
fiber grain but the fiber is you know
there's more hurt than yeah it's uh what
is it like
but depends how you grow it so you're
harvesting Dual Purpose that would be
mostly heard yeah yes before you reach
flowering and you will get mostly fast
which will be that still I will be in
the same proportion but sorry the
proportion will be much less uh you'll
still have more hair yeah and to get
those really high levels of bass fiber
that you're talking about earlier that's
not going to be textile grade it might
be good for non-wovens but I think for
textile grade fibers
earlier right so it's not fully
signified and then you might only see
less than 10 percent
uh well
there's no market for textile grade
fibers but
okay uh I do think there's America in
North Carolina right yeah
foreign
to maximize the past and I think
as long as you get the long fiber which
are the primary bus they are long enough
for a spinning uh you know the longer
you play
mature it will be shorter so again for a
screening that would be very complicated
that's why we have to and also the plant
density is much higher here to maximize
that so we have the independent
competition right so that it triggers
more growth among plants uh you have
longer internal notes I have finer I
mean many papers from Europe claim that
the higher the plant density the finer
the fibers you get
the nutrition as well although that's a
little bit because you have to be
careful with nutrition
um but yeah
could you talk about your planting Davis
uh
you can have
well maybe not here but multiple co-ops
in one year just talking about great
question yes um so these are that into
the flower environment yeah
um so the question was if I could
elaborate more on the plant thanks for
the planting date and uh yeah
the whole the whole process of from
seeing
in the whole like time frame from the
sea from heating to harvest
um so when this trial
so in the handout you will see two
content planting dates
so this entire field was planted on May
18th uh there's a second planting all
the way down there when we walk towards
the end of this field you will see four
blocks that's the second planting that
was uh for the fiber plot that was on
June 9th and for a dual quad that was on
June 30th the reason why I didn't wear
space out is because
um
yeah so the flowering time you see
you see handouts you have different
flowering plants so I think I have
different Criterion for each fiber right
so for Fiverr I harvest it when the
plant reaches 50 flowering
in that way I maximize yield and I
minimize my loss in quality of fiber for
dual I harvest between six to seven
weeks after about 85 percent of the
plants have flour so in that way I
minimize seed shattering I maximize
maturity
and well that also depends on the blood
pressure you have now
the plant delay is a good question
because in the industries claim that
crop is X days and 100 dates and
something like that so if you look at
the handout I can tell you the opposite
however another thing that I want to
mention is that in Europe in 2008 there
was a paper uh talking about Growing
Degree Days having other crop is
commonly done this paper was later
evaluated again in 2012 validated but
after that no one has touched our paper
they came up with uh and some of those
cultivars that they use for that model
are growing right now so what I'm doing
like these two planting dates is to see
environmental effects on these School
divorce planted very early in late
and to see how they've looked right now
um another thing that flowering time
should tell you is the
uh how homogeneous uh the graphics so
if you look at the handout some plants
will reach this flower sorry we will
start flowering from one percent to 50
or one percent to 100 at different rates
depending on when they are planted
uh so that may also be explained by The
Growing Degree Days uh in this model so
I want to explore that I want to look at
into that and which cultivas abide by
that and instead of using x amount of
days it was based on you know I don't
know what they're basing on but uh
indicator is a Formula would be better
indicator flower so you can schedule
your equipment uh in all the processing
and so forth and so on
um however I am very certain that not
all cultivas will abide by that model
because of heavy genetic um effects x59
is one of those will flower about 20 30
days however in the handout you'll see
that it's not good covered
um so I work really hard to put those
data together for you to take advantage
of those numbers and to see the
distinction between this and to say hey
actually your website says 100 and
something but maybe this is not so much
in this in this area now everything
changes the uh lower the lower the light
of the you go to plan these Contours
okay
[Music]
no no
yeah
baby
Vari crowns are a lot of fun because
there's so much genetic diversity
and you probably know these books better
than anyone else so which is your
favorite variety one
um so maybe they're saying that I know
this vlogger than anybody and that's
right
and which one is my favorite cultivar or
variety and why
uh early hours
but
actually question
um 23 11 43 is our brain line uh if you
look around uh one thing you will notice
is the lodging there is lodging going on
uh 23 1143 is the one that's standing
very strong uh another particular
um trait of this green line is a seat
size you may have seen the seats on the
sample size around one that I gave you
guys and you can see the seats are
massive
to soybean so I find that very appealing
and as an agronomist like that's a very
enticing ironic trait they want to
pursue
oh in the late flower and trade as well
so I think that that building line has a
potential uh for either a global purpose
or a grain or sorry a fire cookware
depending on any planted
for all these varieties
for this latitude or did you grow some
that or specific for other latitude just
to see how they're going to do uh I
think the latter yeah so the question
was
uh collaborations with other
universities
um yeah the question is if I decided to
use or to test the school device based
on their uh after related to this
surgeon or I was just testing like
overall all available neural classes so
yeah so I tested with that test cultivas
from different regions uh probably in
order than our thousand of our latitude
from where they're coming from Europe
however our green lines are being tested
across the United States so we have
trials
we have one in North Carolina that even
is helping us phenotype we have one in
Kentucky which is managed by Dr Wolf
peers we have one in Texas uh
Calvin Russell and one in homes tutorial
like my
advisor password
so we're seeing and you can see in the
handout actually that our green lines
have their performing you know
and the different
our yields and benefits that
or not affected by the Light
photo period
that will be the main factor whatever
the fact of like the rainfall
now it's related to your friend Ecuador
yeah and
I've been Decor many times I started the
process educating the government there
in 2013.
and then realized that well there's not
really any uh varieties that will do
well in life cycle for
stalking greatness nothing out but
that's what I was leading to is there
something have you tried have you
brought genetics there I brought today
or grown and seeing me then only get
this tall and go to flower you know
whereas here they get 20 people
oh the question is if
um we have tested or brought germ plasma
from latitude close to the equator uh
and uh I think I don't know if you can
see this but uh
okay
three
yeah I'm curious to put that the larger
seat size is attractive larger seat size
less seats per pound higher uh planting
weight per acre to get the same stand
production costs could go up
so I guess what's attractive from your
perspective about the larger
yeah so the question is uh why am I so
attracted to the seat size even though
I mean less seats per pound and a higher
cost for ceiling and establishment so I
knew whenever we asked a question
um and my counter argument to that is
the strong ceiling Vigor of this General
plasma that will ensure kind of
precaution much earlier than others and
because of that you may require less
seed to get the same stand count
compared to a small CA cultivar that you
require more seats to reach kind of
people closer that it will eventually
lead to self-cleaning so you'll be
losing uh money by the self-learning
individuals of those extra seats that
you're planting so that is my hypothesis
and I'd like to test that next year to
be more accurate not just based on
genotype but also the seat size original
type different size yep good question
it's also a great parent material when
you breed it with others so now you can
see a complete variation in seat size
and you can actually select an idea seed
side during a segregation without a lot
yeah do you have data on that oh there
you go
so the question is if there is variation
in seat size that actually I can take
advantage of and develop cultivars uh
for for example as multilaterals for
fiber production and last year equal to
us for Doppler production uh so you've
got ahead of myself so I have uh Mafi
population which we're comparing uh two
genotypes
irrigating and the the difference
between the currency is astounding is
like feed 50 grams thousand seed weight
compared to five gram thousand Seaway so
we spend all right
[Laughter]
so there could be some major effect
genes that can be used and we can select
for specific General Pleasant that are
small cities or large cities
as long as render was right so
the idea is so that that can help us
develop markers and then we can put it
into our toolkit to uh you know better
General plasma also
um
2011-43 I've been like still working on
it and there are happy with this
irrigation for seat size so the reason
why I was saying earlier that from 2014
I can develop fiber and the wall is
because I've seen this irrigation and I
could do phenotypic record selection to
determine oh these genotypes will be
better for dual and this will be for
fiber
yep but the bottom line is that f1n the
F2 generation of that cross between
large seated and very small seated is
right in the middle it's an additive
trait so Mendel was wrong
we would have expected right if it were
dominant either large or small but it's
clearly a quantitative additive trait
that's going to take a lot of time to
breed back
uh if we want to introgress those traits
and get large seed or a small seed it's
going to take a lot of breeding to do
that
crazy question
how how strong is the relationship
between large seeds and high grade
imagine you're playing this game where
you have
fewer larger seeds versus a greater
number of smaller seeds uh how does that
come out in the wash in terms of overall
feel free here or is there just not a
straw
and maybe as we're walking down maybe
people can sample particular varieties
and look at the same size
because you only have about okay yeah
um could you elaborating your questions
I feel confused yeah yeah no problem so
how strong is the relationship between
yield per acre of grain with seed size
because I imagine there's a game where
a fewer number of large seeds or a
greater number of smaller seeds perhaps
so is that a tight relationship is there
a have you observed yeah so in the in
the handout I put together a the yield
data maybe we should start walking
um
hi my name is Chris I am the plant
pathologist
generally people are not enthusiastic uh
about the plant Pathologists because you
know we deal with rotten plants
but we're here to tell you that we are
also working to deal with producing a
healthier stand more quickly so in my
lab uh for hemp we have people working
on uh Patrick is working on root rot
issues which he'll talk about I have
another student working on septoria leaf
spot which is among the biggest leaf
spot issues here in the state of New
York given the humidity and rain that we
have
uh and then I have a student that's
working on Downey mildew again that's a
water mold that can be really
problematic especially if it gets
established early in the season and we
have a wet season and then finally uh
together with the breeding program we
have a large group of folks working on
powdery mildew which can be an issue in
the field but is absolutely an issue in
high tunnel and Greenhouse ground crops
and in fact we have identified a source
of resistance or technically lack of
susceptibility to powdery mildew that's
now in the breeding program and I am
hopeful as a plant pathologist that the
breeding program will breed all
cultivars to be resistant to powdery
mildew
laughs
I don't know how much influence I'll
have
um but today I would like to introduce
my PhD student
Patrick McMullen and he's going to talk
to you about a seed treatment study that
we're working on he'll start with
talking about the importance of it and
then move into some of the results and
where we're going with it in the future
thank you Chris
um so we've been talking a lot about
above ground traits of uh hemp this
morning
louder
um but you can't really have a healthy
plant without a healthy root system to
support that above ground growth so
we're interested in focusing on
promoting uh early establishment High
densities by promoting good root growth
there's a number of soil-borne pathogens
that can infect root systems and prevent
that good root establishment so these
are among water molds lithium and many
species of pythium can cause stamping
off where you have early seedling death
this pathogen will enter the root system
and essentially Decay the cortex of the
roots where the outer Roots will just
slop off and then die leading to Total
plant collapse
there's also fungal pathogens among
fusarium species and others that will
cause root diseases in older mature
plants that will the fungal hyphy can
grow into the root system clog the
vasculature and prevent water flow
through those upper shoots of the plant
which are going to cause your plants to
wilt and eventually die
so our goal here in this study was to
see if we can
promote the plant to root early
well early in its life cycle by applying
a fungicide seed treatment
so here um this is all in the handout
um so we'll be passing around some
images of root diseases that you can
look at what I was just discussing where
you can see the reddish brown
discoloration on the roots small root
growth and then necrosis and wilting and
plant collapse on the shoots of the land
standing in front of we used four
different fungicide sea treatments and a
non-trade control so there were two
Copper products americop and ultim
and a phosphite and phosphate product
proven 44 and neutral and then we also
included a conventional control of apron
and Maxim
um a combination of two different
fungicides
so these were applied to two different
cultivars we included 5 or 79 and Futura
83. all of the treatments are in both
cultivars and this is organized in a
randomized complete block design all of
the treatments can be found on the if
you scan the QR code here on the field
map if you scroll to the bottom it will
say you see treatments and you can look
at the up
and yes but there's the specific field
map so you could look at which
treatments are here
um so in in this study
I collected uh stand count data at
several time points throughout the
growing season and as you can see it's
not harvested yet so we don't have that
final data but if we're looking at these
numbers here we can see that both ultim
and prudent 44 are neutral significantly
increase the average number of seedlings
per plot so these were just a sample of
a one meter quadrat section from each
plot where we counted the average number
of seeds per treatment
all of the treatments did numerically
improve the stand count density so
americop and the apron and maximum
treatments here weren't significantly
greater than the non-true control but we
still did see a pretty large numeric
increase there and these continued at
the next time point that we measured as
well so there is uh some optimism here
that these seed treatments do improve
our
stand counts and plant establishment
here
um soon I I will be collecting Harvest
data so I'll be measuring biomass and
um
uh fiber quality and content to assess
how these seed treatments correlate to
yield so we want to answer the question
if we see an increase in Stand count as
we're seeing from these data on the
sheet that you have now does that
correlate to yield at the end of the
season
so are we still seeing that Improvement
in yield or can improving the stand
count allow us to reduce the seeding
density that we're using so using less
seed but maybe using a seed treatment to
help us out there
um so I think there's a lot of potential
here we're going to repeat this
experiment next year as well and we
would like to include a biologic
treatment so the treatments that we used
this year were just copper
phosphite and conventional fungicide
two of those americop and ultimar
organic products the other two are not
none of them are labeled on hemp yet but
there is some of that works in the
process for several of these products
but we would like to expand this work
further next year to include biological
products to we'll for sure
yeah we all have a bacillus and
liquidations product to test
um just to give Growers more options and
different strategies for control
um and I think I would like to take any
questions you might have about sea
treatments or diseases diseases in
general
yes effective
um so that's it
yeah so the question was how expensive
is the seed treatment or is it cost
effective
um we don't have those data yet because
we can't correlate it to heal
um I don't know if you have any idea and
how much it would cost
I don't no so it's such a small volume
that generally seed treatments tend to
be more cost effective than treatments
once plants are established and
especially if the cost of hemp seed is
so high that if we can reduce the number
of seeds needed by applying a seed
treatment that could be a great way to
um
we will have those data probably by the
end of next year after we have enough
enough reps yeah so more information on
that to come
okay
the currency costs
yeah the question is uh what is the
price of seed and we have a number of
seeds uh sales people here uh who can
answer that question to you directly so
Sarah Mitchell of Kings AG received is
here
Corby minute of canopy us is here
uh there's Corby and uh I I would say
our goal as a plant breeder and uh
uh you can we can talk to Trey Trey asks
a good question to Luis it's probably
three dollars a pound
and again then you have to think about
your seating rate
you're seating for brain production at
25 pounds per acre but for five or we're
seating some at a hundred pounds
uh so those are important economic
questions we need to work out with our
agronomists uh and uh let me just follow
up Patrick's talk by saying here that in
in many of these small plot trials and
we've done these uh with collaborators
academic collaborators across the
country uh you know Ernie's is a good
example uh we rarely see greater than 50
percent seed establishment
so we're seating you know at a live seat
rate based on germination tests and then
coming out and doing stand counts and we
rarely see more than 50 of those live
seeds turning into an established
a good portion of that is probably due
to soil-borne pathogens so the work that
Patrick's doing you know is critical to
increase that rate of stand
establishment because 50 of this seed
that you're growing doesn't turn into it
that your planting doesn't turn into a
plant
right so then you have to plant twice as
many seeds to get the stand that you
want and that's not economical either
so you know I I would have said
in the industry that uh again four years
ago one of our biggest problems was
getting high quality seed that high
germination rate because it was all
coming in from Europe
uh you know and we were always the last
thought right but now that we have folks
like Corby uh bringing in hempit rise
from France in a timely manner and
storing it properly uh
uh and now we have domestic seed
production from companies like
International hemp uh and Canadian good
Canadian seed from uni seeds and Verve
uh and New West genetics all
domestically produced I think we now
have overcome that barrier in terms of
the quality of seed so that you when you
buy a seed lot and expect it to be 90
germination rate
you can get that now
whereas you couldn't get that four years
ago so now we need to move on to these
other problems like uh you know seed
treatments and getting herbicides
approved and that's our next topic
uh and I'd like to introduce vipin Kumar
who is our new field crop wheat
scientist at Cornell
uh to talk about how we finally have an
herbicide product labeled and registered
for hemp that we can use and
unfortunately our
uh wheat scientists here at agritech
Lynn sosnowski could not join us she's
at a conference in North Carolina but
bippin is going to quickly present some
encouraging results from Lynn's group
right
thank you Larry good morning everyone
morning
what are you guys doing so far great
great good good well uh as Larry
mentioned I'm uh I'm a new to Cornell
I'm a new wheat scientist with a field
crops
um I have a counterpart here Dr Lynn
susnowski who has been actively leading
a sum of uh weed Management program in
ham
a little bit about my background uh
before joining Cornell I was with Kansas
State for more than five years and I was
working in Western cases in hotel
Dryland agriculture
mainly working with the crops like
sorghum wheat Dryland corn a little bit
soybean as well as the sunflower a lot
of fallow ground
as you know in High Plains the moisture
is limited and fallow based cropping
system is predominant
as you know no-till dry land
you're not you're not able to do a
tillage so you're relying on herbicides
for me control
and repeated use of herbicides over the
decades has created a problem like
herbicide resistant weeds so my role was
there to come up with the strategies to
to tackle those herbicides
so jumping in a corner uh I'm gonna go
and do kind of see
uh in terms of developing a beat
management programs in field crops so
part of my responsibilities here is to
come up with a sustainable weed control
strategies in field crops including corn
soybean Alfalfa as well as small grains
so as I said I'm a six month old in
Cornell and not aware about this new
crop hemp but Lynn kind of gave me a
quite an overview of what's going on in
terms of weed control and you guys might
have a handout here uh what has been
going on in terms of weed control
research in kernel agritech here in
Geneva
just a few uh very you know foundational
points I like to Hammer as I do with
other crops is uh
as you know hemp compared to other crops
is a relatively new crop uh so we don't
have many options when I say options I
talk about herbicide options we don't
have many herbicide options to go with
for weed control
uh but fortunately uh work from Dr Lynn
cisnos em other colleagues from USDA
we were able to have a supplemental
label with one of the herbicide in the
New York this year
and that herbicide is the sauna land
from Govan company
if you know or most of you know probably
a group three or root growth Inhibitors
this herbicide belongs to group three uh
you know herbicide side of actions so
ital Floral in is the active
and it is a label for both type of hemp
and the rate is 1.5 to 3 points per acre
and you can you know select the rate
based on your soil type
as well as you know other conditions
so uh one important thing about the
sonaline is is a pre and uh you know
pre-planned applied herbicide so you
probably have to incorporate this this
herpeside when you're applying that
and that can be done with the
irrigations or rainfall or you if
there's no rainfall or no irrigation
available you probably have to do that
incorporation mechanic mechanically so
incorporation is a very very important
and this group is basically a root
growth Inhibitors as I said uh Target
maturity of the grass species uh give
grass species including Barnyard or
crabgrass but also has activity on Broad
leaves like big weeds so that's a good
news in the hemp industry that we have a
herpeside which you can you know use for
for weed control
and uh in general the feed control why
weed control is important in hair
like other crops if you allow weeds to
grow especially in the early season like
within one to four weeks after planting
or transplanting uh you're gonna see the
impact on the yield as well as the
quality in the ham so early season
competition is really really critical
and I've been hearing from Larry and
others uh you know very good work in
terms of reading lines developing traits
for good economic trades I would also
probably see collaborations and work
with Larry and others in the Futures to
see if we have some potential and
opportunities to select some lines that
has a competitive Advantage compared to
the weeds because we need those lines we
need those uh you know cultivars having
a comparative advantage than weeds
so other than that you know that that
handout also covers a lot of cultural
practices you know very you know
understandable things which we can do to
to avoid weeds basically preventive
measures you know don't grow hemp in in
the fields where you know there is a lot
of seed bank wheat seed bank basically
selective
uh you know proper timing planting time
I see there's been three timings for
some of these varieties has been planted
uh I think that is a good approach to
optimize that proper timing because some
of these competitive weeds are also
coming at that time at that time and if
you have a proper timing you can Avail
the opportunity to control those weeds
before you plant your craft uh let those
those weeds come and then you control
this some some sort of burn down or some
other methods of weed control and then
plant so site selections planting time
seeding rate a lot of interest in
seeding rates and why large seed and
versus small seed I guess Larry made a
good point having a good bigger uniform
germination uniform emergence is really
critical when we are dealing with early
season wheat competition so that you
have a good canopy of the crop that can
express the wheat early in the season
so again you know cultural practices uh
control weeds in rotational crops the
one of the major hurdle in in terms of
hemp we don't know much about the crop
tolerance or crop plant back
restrictions from most of the chemicals
we use in our rotational crops things
like in corn and soybeans so that is a
big big hurdle to really bring more
herbicide oxygen into the crop or use
herbicide in rotational crafts so I
would say select integrated approach
integrator weed management approach rely
on other options like a cultural
practices as well as mechanical
practices you can rely on some sort of
Intel cultivation into remoing if you
have planted those hemp in a standard
rows
along with you know herbicide maybe
rotational crabs once in a while uh if
you can so those are kind of the major
uh points
um I I had any any question you guys
have for me yes is there going to be
different uh herbicides you can use
based on different Market classes so say
you could use one for fiber grain
production but not one for cannabinoid
production yeah that's a good question
and I wish
uh the question is if they're going to
be a herbicide options available for
different classes for example for fiber
or for green or for other types uh I
guess I wish and everybody wish that
that is the case but in case of
herbicides uh labeling and registrations
there's not a lot a lot a lot of
interest from the industry standpoint
because of the smaller industry the hemp
industry I'm saying as well as the crop
tolerance and and the crop plant back
restrictions of course there has been
some work with ir4 has been going on
looking at other options other tools
herbicide tools and Lynn mentioned that
there's a quite a good uh results with
the kizal of class one herbicides for
grass control but again uh you know
where that stands in terms of
registrations uh still in the future
similarly she has been looking to to
look at some of the group 15s as metola
Chlor acetophlore type materials in
conjunction with sonal and so that you
can extend the residual activity for
season long weed control but again those
are non-label herbicides in the hemp and
I guess there's a more work needs to be
done
any other question yes
question is if I'm doing any work with
the inter planting uh I'm not as I said
I'm just developing my program
and my major role is in field crops and
when I was thinking of hemp especially
for green type I think that falls
probably under field crops
and yeah I have not done any work maybe
Larry has any any information on that
yeah so that's a great question uh I was
just talking with Sarah Mitchell and
she's working on a system in
Pennsylvania of planting a nurse crop
with hemp and then I think you also want
to talk to Professor Ginny Moore uh in
plant breeding at Cornell who is uh
breeding cover crops and I think has
been looking at planting hemp into cover
crops as well so that's a great question
uh just to touch on your question
the uh if you are growing for CBD or
high THC cannabis
uh that tissue will be tested and those
tests often include a test for pesticide
residue so there may well be a different
herbicide regime that you're going to
use for CBD hemp or cannabis versus
grain and fiber based on that tissue
residue testing
yeah uh have you done any soil testing
before the crop was planted and after to
see was it like you know some chemicals
were detrimental to the soil and that
type of stuff yeah that's a great
question the question is uh about doing
pre-planting soil testing
in particular to look for any uh
elements in the soil or pesticide
residues perhaps that might get into
your crop that I would highly recommend
that doing that for CBD hemp again
because of the post-harvest testing
regimes
although we do not have a good
understanding for example at the levels
of cadmium in the soil that may lead to
high levels of cadmium in the pleural
tissue so it's a great question about
doing those tests but
uh by my understanding we we don't have
good predictive ability to say how the
results of those tests will end up in
uh residues in your harvested crop for
example
what we do know is that hemp can be very
tolerant of heavy metals yeah that's
that's that's the thing because it it
can suck up heavy metals out of the soil
what happens to the biomass if we want
to use it for construction for example
yeah are we storing those heavy metals
inside the walls of your house yeah so
the question again is if if you test if
you test and observe high levels of
cadmium in the soil
will that cadmium end up in the stems
and then end up in your hemp creek
uh and I'm focusing on cadmium because
that is uh probably the main element
that uh hemp is good at taking up heavy
metal there are a lot of heavy metals uh
and hemp is not going to take up all of
those heavy metals but cadmium is one in
particular
uh so we we made a little demonstration
of samal in here we planted this little
trial on August 3rd and between the
there are two replica strips uh the blue
was
not treated with sonolin the yellow
strips were treated with two pints per
acre of salmon
uh Lynn surveyed those plots I think
three weeks after planting and there was
no significant difference in the wheat
competition
and that's mainly because the main weed
that we had coming up was field Penny
crust and Solomon specifically says on
the label that it does not control Neil
Penny crust
so uh that again highlights that we need
a range of methods as vipin said an
integrated weed management approach
and it all starts with keeping weeds out
of your fields for the start so thanks
very much
you mentioned diseases and weeds and
everything have you guys have any uh
have experienced any problem with
insects
uh
okay so the question is do we have any
insect pests and again we have been
working with
uh started working with Elson Shields
who was our field crops entomologist and
uh more recently have been working with
Marion zooflu zuffly and integrated Pest
Management who have been doing insect
surveys uh for a few years now and to be
honest we do not have any uh insect
pests that are causing economic damage
in New York after several years of
surveys
have you seen aphids oh we yeah we see
aphid we see cannabis safe in the field
but it doesn't really uh uh our our
conclusion at this point is that it is
not causing economic damage
all of these fields have been tilt yeah
we have not done much work on no-till
Sarah
grain market
because not everybody wants to grow a 50
this is that a shorter
green variety
more
I guess
appropriate for farmers who aren't yet
willing to spend tens of thousands on
new equipment and that I guess the
reason for that question is about
insects in the grain so
have you how much emphasis are you
looking at for grain and and
all Associated diseases and insects okay
so Sarah is asking about our emphasis in
terms of Market class of hemp uh so
again I would classify that we have
varieties that are best suited as a
grain only dedicated grain crop that are
easy to harvest with conventional
combines
uh we're today promoting I'll say we're
promoting Dual Purpose crops uh partly
because we want to demonstrate that
Double Cup combine grain and fiber and
also because I think the market growth
potential right now is in the herd and
fast areas
as we all know man silver Harvest
there's a lot of grain in in Canada
and they can Harvest that with those
whatever 60 foot wide combines out there
uh whatever they are uh
I'm going to defer your question till
the afternoon when we're talking about
the double cut
uh because we are going to see some
strip trials out there that did not
reach the height that we need for the
Double Cup
so I definitely think there is a need
and a market for dedicated grain only
varieties once we get grain approved as
an animal feed that's going to open up
that market
and we want Farmers to put those crops
in rotation with their other small
cereal grains that they can Harvest with
their combine
okay we need to move on uh
um as Larry said we've been uh
certified organic now it's I think we
started transition in 1992 I was I was
three I don't really remember that so my
whole life we've been organic uh my
viewpoint is not what can we get in a
jug to get what can we get registered so
we can handle the weeds it's how do we
manage the weeds mechanically that's my
whole
view on this
um we're farming about 1900 Acres of
organic ground we process seed so and we
do a lot of unusual things so when uh
hemp licensing started in 2018 we jumped
right on and tried to grow hemp and it
was a horrible disaster I guess we were
focused on on grain production and we
were running with a relatively low
population
and
then we had some crusting issues and uh
we didn't have an adequate population to
manage the weeds and we didn't Harvest
anything two years in a row and we gave
up the license because it just wasn't
really working
um and Larry tried to pull me back into
hemp production a couple of times since
then and I was not real interested until
this year when I ran into this machine
when I was in Germany visiting my wife's
family
um
it was a curiosity so I went to visit
the company and they told me that they
have four machines running in
Saskatchewan on hemp on an 8.6 by 8.6
spacing dropping two seeds at each point
uh they've dramatically reduced their
seeding rate and they've increased
yields and they have some side by side
pictures then they realized they
shouldn't have told me so much and
wouldn't tell me who was doing this
all right
but in trying this we brought it in to
grow red beets
and we're going to grow azuki beans but
we decided to try some hemp as well
working with a licensed grower
we were focused on seed production so we
went with a 15 inch row spacing with a
nine inch in row spacing
we were dropping two to three seeds at
each seeding point so that the seeds
were able to help each other out
[Music]
it's not a uniform spacing but it'll
drop seating was a common practice 100
years ago
before some of our modern technology
came along
so
we had by my calculations about 120 000
seeds per acre maybe 140 000 seeds per
acre and where the machine did what it
was supposed to we have a perfectly
clean field I say where it did what it
it was supposed to because there's a
huge learning curve with this technology
this is an autonomous robot
it did all of the planting it recorded
the GPS location of every seed to the
nearest half centimeter
that's why as two GPS receivers on top
we had to install our own base station
one of our landlords actually has worked
for the Navy and he said how are you
getting it that accurate right yes
I don't know he was aware that that
accuracy was possible but didn't realize
that it was open civilians
so the the principle of the machine is
to drop every seat know precisely where
it is and then come back in later even
pre-emergence and cultivate between
those seeds with a a knife on an arm
that is able to travel back and forth
between the seating points you can do
that on as little as 100 millimeters so
four inches of space between seeds
so I think there is space to
increase seating rate decrease the space
between seeds with this technology
um
I sent Larry a few pictures I think they
went up of nearly clean under canopy
views also some videos of it working
between plants and because I don't know
what you're all interests might be I'm
going to open it up for questions
boss
uh right around 100 000 U.S
there is not currently an importer in
the United States this came in through
Canada uh they've been putting a lot of
pressure on me to be an importer don't
have time
uh so service is all coming out of
Canada but I think we're going to see
that changing probably within the next
12 months economics return on investment
uh at this point I believe this is very
much a proven concept thing so we're not
as focused on that I think that the
return on investment has to do with high
value props so if this can be used on a
farm that is growing vegetables that is
growing
also hemp maybe some other fiber crops
like flax where your seeding period is
stretched throughout the season and your
cultivation period is stretched
throughout the season the return is
going to be a lot better it can
theoretically handle 15 acres per day it
does run 24 hours a day
so
just spreading out the period when it
needs to be used is going to really
increase the Acres that you can cover in
a year a year and decrease the cost per
acre the the operating cost per acre is
practically zero yeah it's really just
the wearing elements because all of the
energy comes from the solar panels
thank you
24 hours but solar panels so what kind
of storage of the energy that you have
to run if you're going to let it plant
after
it has a set of Lithium-ion batteries on
board the solar panels produce up to
1600 watts of power and the maximum
power requirement of the machine is
1100.
so it will charge through the day there
is a second set of batteries that can be
put on if needed
some of the users in Europe that I talk
to are actually mounting like a little
600 watt inverter type generator on it
and going out turning it on at 10
o'clock at night to charge the battery
while it continues working and shut it
off when the sun comes up in the morning
it's self-propelled it is self-propelled
the tractor is not needed for no it is
fully autonomous once you map the points
in the field and any obstacles it
develops a plan of where it's going to
drive and then executes the plan that's
the deal is stones in the soil it
doesn't particularly like stones soil
preparation is extremely important it's
Stony here it is Stony here I would say
that we are stonier down 10 miles south
of here in Penn Yan the glaciers had a
lot of fun on our farm
um I've been picking Stone since I was
big enough to pick them up and I think
my grandma I think they grow I think
that the soil is ending up in the lake
all right so soil preparation is a huge
deal this is very much focused any
Horticultural model where you are paying
much more attention to the soil than in
Broad acre production
but that's a great Point Jack that yeah
mechanical cultivation uh is very very
challenging on Stony soil we have a lot
of those in here
One of a Kind competition anything else
like this there are some other companies
in Europe there's a I think a lot more
of a grant funding program in the EU for
autonomy because labor costs are higher
there's another company from Denmark
called roboti uh Kong skilled was
working in this for a while uh but I
believe when they were bought by case
New Holland that kind of went in a
different direction
um there is a company called nio in
France that is working on this and there
is a raven in Canada is working on a
much larger scale version of this
what's happening it's impressive okay
Kudos you mentioned this deep learning
curve what sort of obstacles did you
have to go through uh we prepared the
ground like we would for our normal uh
cultivation equipment and planting
equipment and it wasn't happy uh it
didn't like the amount of residue that
was on top it didn't like how loose the
soil was
and it
uh
the first crop that we planted with it I
had I think 300 text messages that
something went wrong in the course of a
day and a half
how does that cover the seed
it goes this way it's currently set up
mostly in weeding configuration this row
unit is set up for planting
there is one item missing because I
forgot to bring it up from the farm
which is a closing shoe that goes on the
back behind the primary press wheel
before the secondary press
but moves in this direction correct yeah
it's impressive other questions
yeah what about inroad cultivation yes
it uh
there is a Servo motor
and he
it's on now so it's not being
cooperative it doesn't like to move but
that Servo motor moves an arm in and out
that arm carries a knife and is able to
cultivate between seating points that it
has mapped during the seating process
hopefully the video is up on our website
you can see it
that'll be one of the most popular ones
okay thanks very much Peter
[Music]
exception Mark we really appreciate
Cornell and Dr smart working with us and
giving us the opportunity to build this
machine this is the first mobile
decorticator that's been built and and
functional in the U.S we built the
smaller one that was in Russia in 2018
that's still running but it's a hand-fed
single stock machine but we've been
making Machinery since 2016 2017. uh
believe it or not we started on
decortication back then when it was not
a thing that nobody was interested in it
and at the time we thought we would make
the corticators which the coordinator is
just the second piece he's kind of been
pieces right here this is the
decorticator it's a roller breaker style
machine Believe It or Not based on the
1905 slickton model the got imp band in
the first place and we figured if it
worked then it would work now and being
a good German he put a bunch of stuff in
his bed and it didn't work and we spent
a couple years figuring that out but
we've got a technique
that if you've got a crop that has grown
with intent for fiber and
grown on you know 3 8 of an inch maybe
half inch diameter stalks does a very
good job of separating if the crops have
been breaded and properly put up which
we're learning more about that all all
the time we also Farm hemp in Colorado
you know in 2014 2015 when CBD started a
bunch of people got into it and a bunch
of people got burned so it's a little
difficult for us to get contract labor
or contract farming done in Colorado so
we actually just break ground and farm
it ourselves and then we know
what what we're going to get uh Dr smart
mentioned uh Global fiber I do most of
the r d for Global fiber and formation
but we've come out with a structural
load-bearing hemp block that is not
increased its actual structural uh in in
a cinder block configuration
construction masonry unit it'll hold
2500 pounds per cubic foot normal cinder
blocks are 1500 and we've got three or
four more products it is we keep working
on them that you'll get to see them and
it all starts with this it was is an
evolution in trying to figure out where
can we take the 25 000 uses for it where
can we make a dollar at it because we
have to pay for all this stuff and and
we've we've come up with some pretty
Innovative value-add and agricultural
products that we could do with him he
mentioned the hauling that's a great
thing I wish more people would eat it
we'd have a lot more dehullers around
this cinder block deal that we came up
with changes to me changes the Paradigm
to for agriculture because this is not
just hundreds of Acres it's tens of
thousands of acres to supply this block
there are 522 billion cinder blocks made
in the US every single year if we took a
tenth of a percent of that market we
would need 690 000 acres of hemp growth
that's a difference I mean that makes a
difference in our area water is a very
big thing conservation of water we can
grow a hemp crop on seven to eight
inches of water where potatoes between
26 and 28 inches of water alfalfas 28 to
32 this year was really hot they went
even more so it's a great technique for
conserving water and all the other soil
health benefits that him does for
compaction organic matter Etc but that's
that's why we keep pushing for AG to
adopt more hemp Acres it's not easy if
you want to be in him it's dirty Dusty
nasty frustrating work sometimes but
it's the right thing to do so we think
that's good work and that's why we keep
investing our money in it so so this
machine starts with a veil in feed you
would think that you can just unwind hip
on a hay bale machine but you can't
turns out we've tried a bunch of them it
doesn't work very well because a hip
prop and any other crop really doesn't
always grow perfectly consistent we
don't have hundreds of years of reading
and when you drive down the field and
you see a corn field all the years are
pretty much at the same height they're
almost all the same stature
doesn't grow like that we have hip
fields that are four feet tall and then
go 20 feet and it's 10 feet tall 12 feet
tall
so we had to innovate something that
could handle that and meter the flow of
the material Downstream into the machine
so we came up with this machine and what
it is is it's unrolling the bail kind of
the opposite direction of as it was
wound up and then we're shearing off a
certain thickness right now it's set for
an inch and a quarter mat we can go up
to two or three inches we can go down a
little bit but we've found an inch and a
quarters roughly where it needs to be so
that the machine can more efficiently
work it's a little counter the thinner
the mat you feed to this machine the
faster you can run because the the
corticator can do more work on the
thinner mat that again thicker you'd
think that would be opposite but it's
not this machine also tips up on the
incline if you need more pressure
against the sharing device but
that that's that piece of machine in our
facility based ones we put dust hoods
over the top to collect the dust because
our Bales sit outside we live in the
desert sand gets blown into them and it
just creates dust so we we have dust
collection and at altitude dust
collections are real pain we live at
eight thousand feet so it's kind of a
nuisance 7 700 feet
the main machine
is up up there open those doors so they
can see the gearing on it
it looks simple but that that second
section right here that he's opening the
doors on that's 12 000 pounds of steel
that's about what it takes to break this
crop apart the more humid it is the more
work it takes
so we engineer that those years so that
we can let those Springs compress the
Springs are putting pressure on the
stock
and we're working it gradually as we go
you can't just start decorticating you
have to break it up get it softer and
then those rollers get faster as it goes
through the machine so not only do we
kind of break it apart but we're but
we're brushing the material off of the
herd off of the fiber and that's what
makes that work you can push a button in
the top half of that machine opens up
because hip made really good rope right
you hear that about the saline chips and
all that it still makes really good rope
and if there's a round spot that him can
wrap on it we'll find it when we start
this thing up we're sitting at about a
three degree angle away from us and it's
making the fiber run towards the right
hand side of the machine so that's uh
it's kind of a pain but I bought a jack
a minute ago and lifted it up we'll see
what it does so that's what the
decorticator looks like and then we
always had
hurt gets entangled in the fiber this
machine a normal roller breaker can only
stake straight stops but the way we feed
it and the way we've innovated this
machine we can take round bale
unoriented stocks and it actually turns
the stocks as they go through the
machine to brush the herd off but
there's always a little bit of
entanglement between the herd and the
fiber so the next piece we call it a
Shaker table pretty creative name but
that's all we got and it looks like it's
shaking up and down but it's actually
the ellipse it throws the material up in
the air material starts to come down
then it impacts the material again
knocks a little bit more of the herd out
it's still not perfect
so that next piece of Machinery is a
hurt cleaner it's an old piece of
Machinery we upcycle them we try to be
environmentally friendly we change a
little bit of the guts on the inside of
it that separates what fiber is left on
The Herd as best it can
away from the herd sends the herd down
to the last piece of Machinery the fiber
that comes out of here goes out to the
we call it short fiber side it's in it
is it's just short fiber but the goal of
the overall machine because we want to
make industrial textiles meaning not
closed kind of stuff but clothing too we
want as long a fiber as we could
possibly get when you clean and refine
hip fiber down to where you can get it
to be spun you have to start with a
really long fiber the fibers in these
bags are bundles they're not individual
fibers by far an individual hip fiber is
about 75 80 millimeters long and and I
forget the microns it's you know human
hair thickness it's pretty tiny but to
get to that you have to start with
really long virus we can always cut
something down natural fiber right we
can't make it any longer so this
technique is geared towards long line
fiber ultimately so that we can make
very strong cordage I came out of
plastic so I call them tape still but
they they call them yarn so you want to
know the yarn count of your fiber right
so when we we break this down we've got
if if this was a full system there'd be
another semi-trailer sitting here that
would clean and refine the fiber and
we're learning more and more about that
all the time we've developed some
techniques where we think well we know
we can open fiber up to the point where
it can be spun without cartridge chain
guilds or Combs which is really neat
nobody's ever done that in the world so
and that's that's another one of our r d
projects we're not done with it we
self-fund all this stuff so it takes us
way longer than it should to innovate
some things sometimes but so we call
this first build fiber
coming out of the machine on the bottom
is the first milled herd then we clean
the the short fiber off the herd when
the herd comes out of this large gray
machine here it goes into the one that's
on the nose of the trailer that's going
to separate it into small medium and
large Parts small is like floor dry
kitty litter things like that the medium
size the way it's set right now is
Builder grade herd or animal bedding
it's half an inch to an inch oversized
product the way we've got set right now
is in inches to inch and a half just the
way we're transporting it we uh because
it's on a trailer and we didn't have a
lot of room we usually use conveyors to
move the Earth
but we had to innovate something
different so we're moving it with air we
don't move the fiber with air especially
when it's long because air turns into
vortex in a tube when you're conveying
things long fiber turns into a giant
rope and then it becomes very hard to
machine after that so we still use
conveyors until we've broken it down to
you know six eight inch pieces just
depends on what you're running we do see
white varieties and genetics
harvesting techniques ready techniques
all Impact decortication so you can set
yourself up for success by controlling
your farming practice your Harvest
practice when it comes to that
structural load-bearing bra we're trying
to go from seed all the way to the
finished product to control the spec
because that product will be stamped by
an engineer that's doing the building
this block the engineers at University
of Nebraska with that load rating say we
can go four stories high and it's a true
structural deal you still need hempcrete
you still hempcrete is an insulated
product it's not structural hip Crete is
21 pounds per cubic foot load bear
styrofoam there's nothing there so you
still need that for insulation so the
whole plant you can still use for
building material is it's just
fascinating to me what all we can do
with this product
um
no one else you want to know about it
but that's kind of the machine that
really excited to have this thing
running and here it's it's a pretty
unique deal we ran it at our shop we're
really happy with it and trucked it uh
1900 miles over here one thing I do know
is the US does not build very good roads
in the mid part of the country so we
spent three days tightening things that
I never thought we would tighten so but
we did so if something's banging around
that's why because Ohio and Indiana have
really crappy rooms so New York roads I
got I told Dr smart one thing I thought
I would never do is drive my semi east
of the Mississippi and I was really
happy with the roads here and he said
yeah because we tax everybody but it
does work you have great roads here so I
was happy to see that so but I'm sure we
got questions in a group of this side
just feel free to answer ask them all so
I'll do my best it runs standard cinder
block size 8 by 8 by 16 hollow we've run
six by six by one pavers we're around
three by three by eight bricks it is
formulated and engineered to run on
existing screencast manufacturing lines
that's how it's formulated
[Music]
we've got three years of time and money
into that uh and we figured out the
chemistry of it and it uses no Portland
cement no sand no aggregate aggregate
think of the hemp is kind of replacing
The Rock Yard it is the West industry
that we usually find it
[Music]
you know we think it can be done like
that she asked if it could be molded or
3vd printed it flows so yeah if if you
can pump it it can be moved uh it's
amazing it's it's fairly
[Music]
when it comes out of the volumetric
mixers and they vibrate it it flows like
it's wet still I like water I I don't I
still haven't figured that out either of
the instructions in your garden but it
flows just like a normal Precast zero
slump cement
yeah yeah well it's we sell the herd and
the wet chemistry part of it the the
goal is to license she asked me if it's
available the goal is to license block
manufacturers
to work with Architects and builders in
in regions and then set up facilities
like this to supply those regions you
know if it's Omaha Nebraska or you know
out here in Cornell I'm sure there's a
Precast company and you've got Farmers
that want to grow him you fed up set up
a facility you start feeding herd into
that manufacturing plant
potential
uh some of the short fiber he asked if
um we send material to Heaven texture
the short fiber that comes off the back
is is what temperature buys they want
short small fibers for their uh
cellulose bad insulation products
[Music]
Believe It or Not hip is
the the question was uh fire
preventative measures
you don't cut on this machine you don't
weld or Grind On It Believe It or Not
hemp dust is not explosive we've sent it
off and had it tested we did that here
too and with the order for Cornell but
it will smolder for about an hour or so
if it's if it's a spark and then
[Music]
we've never had a fire knock on wood in
the six years we've been running with
the corticators in our facility we're
careful to clean heaters we clean light
fixtures we have fire extinguishers
laying around but how come would we've
never had a catch on fire we did have a
little pile sitting out in the parking
lot after a rainstorm one day and it got
hot after that and I I don't know if
somebody was cutting out there but it
caught on fire but we've been very
fortunate not to have it hip does burn
and when it does it burns really neat
but it takes a long time and energy to
get it going
so that that's a great question to
people
you know it will burn
when it burns it's hot I mean uh follow
up with that question part of the reason
why uh this Machinery is mounted on a
trailer is because
the Cornell facilities and environmental
health and safety folks reviewed this
entire project
came up with specs for the building
that we would need to contain it
to achieve Cornell standards and one of
our Engineers Scott the Hollander is
here who's going to test all this and
Amy Fox our ehms person is here as well
uh
that would have been a more than two
million dollar facility to construct new
with all of the proper fire and
explosion Hazard equipment so uh Corbett
Corbett is a
uh
Works in a different regulatory
environment than we do I'll just say
that uh but that is we are only allowed
to operate this machine Outdoors that's
why it's on the trailer so we are
building a barn that will protect it
from the elements and then
have a little trolley that will build it
that will pull it out of the building
for operation
of course the other reason to have it on
trailer is to be able to move it around
the state and we want to bring it to
Henry Gage in Ulster County
you want to bring it to uh there's Henry
uh we want we want to bring it to
Henry's farm and show how it works we
want to bring it to the North Country we
want to bring it to Western New York
that
let me just say that hopefully within
the month I will be posting an
advertisement for research support
specialist
to to manage this machine to operate it
and hopefully with a CDL truck driver's
license so that person can drive it
around the state so if you know of
someone
an engineer with farming experience as
well
to operate this machine have them look
out for that job at this posted
another couple other questions here yeah
um
bail and how what's the time and what's
the tonnage per day of going through the
system sure
he's asking is it still on
now there you go he was asking what is
the weight of this Bale and the
throughput on the machine uh we bail our
our hemp in five foot round bales and
they're 1100 1200 1300 pounds roughly if
you make them too loose they don't like
to run very well if you make them two
thousand pounds if there's any flour
left on them they stick together and
they're really hard to unwind
so throughput wise figured like this if
you're just running herd the problem
here is is how do you take away the
fiber fast enough it'll run you know at
least a ton an hour we've got some
automatic machines to pull the fiber
away we get a ton and a half an hour on
this machine
this would be a slightly slower just
because it doesn't have some of the
extra automation Parts on it there's
another question I want to ask you about
this stuff yes
you know we ran he's asking me how much
dust we ran one of one of the Cornell's
Bales last night
um we live in a desert so this Bale's
got sand in it uh the Bale we ran last
night didn't have a whole lot of Dusty a
bunch of rocks in it but it didn't have
a lot of dust so it varies by how it was
harvested where you store we store all
this stuff outside because we live in a
desert so it never really gets wet we
get six inches right in here our
facility is in a large potato storage
Warehouse that we bought if our bills
get wet we send them up on top of the
culverts and turn on the fan for 10-12
hours and they're they're down to four
percent moisture which I don't even know
if you hit that low here we try to bail
it at 15 to 18 just like you do a year
north of 18 moisture I would not nail it
because this stuff will get hot
question back here sir
I thought I saw another one
nope the Flies yes sir can you talk a
little bit about
um
the characteristics of the varieties
that run best through here in terms of
decortication you talk a little bit
about long fibers and one of the things
I'm noticing is there's kind of two
different camps and the fiber varieties
you got some that have no branching and
some that have lots of branching have
you noticed like like what are some of
the best characteristics you're looking
for in fiber to run through this the
seed salesman wants to know what
varieties we do right
no no I just want to talk about
characteristics so characteristics these
are observations that we made over the
years running fiber we've probably
touched more of it than than anybody we
run Chinese stuff Colorado stuff feral
crops
um growth nodes are a problem the herd
likes to stick where there's a growth
though where there's ranching so
we drill everything on six inch centers
we put in about 450 to 550 000 seats per
acre that gives us between a quarter
inch diameter stock at 3 8 of an inch
which gives us thick enough herd that
the builders are happy but not enough
growth nodes that we have lots of issues
with the fiber so that tight spacing can
help reduce the ranching because it
forces the the buds to go up to try and
get to the sun right they're competing
with themselves
um
[Music]
genetics wise we've run Futura
all the signatures
run really good carbon Yola runs good
I'm not 100 sure what this is our Bales
are 60 inches this one's 68. so I'm not
sure where this one came from but I
think it's a French variety that was
grown in Nebraska two years ago by one
of our other partners he's got a couple
sections of ground in Alliance Nebraska
and uh I think that's one of his fails
but I'm not exactly sure what it is
um what other genetics would we run
we've run
Yuma we've run the Chinese Yuma there is
a Yuma crossbow that was bred in eastern
Colorado and the guy also made one
called A1 and A2 and man I wish he would
have not stopped eight one and A2 A1 was
a little hot 8-2 both of those made the
best fiber I've heard and grain that
we've run and when CBD crashed in 2019
he quit
and we got about a pound of that seed
left and I don't know how to throw it
out in the greenhouse nor do I have time
but it is oh yeah but it made we've
taken that fiber to North Carolina to
their textile School
and they have spun it and didn't even
realize it was a dual purpose green crop
right common knowledge says oh it has to
be grown like fiber to be used in
textiles well that's all we had we sent
it to him and he said yeah this stuff's
really great and then we brought some
another little batch with it he said
well this wasn't Reddit because it's the
colors different we live in the desert
we don't get great and uh he had no idea
he was running that stuff the whole time
so
I think propagation technique and
genetics are important
processing technique is almost more
important in my mind of separating the
fiber and it depends on what you want to
do with this stuff if you're making
cellulose insulation for for temperature
you you could probably get away with
something different and a different
technique than what we have here but
again we're trying to do
fibers I came out of the Plastics injury
strain made non-woven and Rochelle knit
products and converted it into fresh
produce packaging potato bags onion bags
any bag you buy in the grocery store
that's got a non-woven mesh on it we
innovated that in in the mesh that it's
made on so we're trying to do things
like that they consume miles of material
not yards of material just a little
different
position in the marketplace because we
see those as better value-added products
that will let us take care of the
farmers better you know if you look at
the diesel price and gas price in the
last few days it jumped up well when
that happens fertilizer will go up we
paid 430 bucks a ton for fertilizer this
year is more last year well what's that
what's that mean is we're paying 300
we'll probably have to jump to 400 a ton
to pay the farmers next year to grow it
if we
when we do it ourselves we still have to
pay for land and for fertility and we
have to pay for water so that that cost
has to roll down to the farm and without
Farmers participating in this and making
a dollar at it it's really hard to keep
things going
so that's really important to take care
of our farm
so I'm going to cut off questions for
now uh we have plenty of time over lunch
or to continue asking questions of
Corbett but if you want to get the
machine started
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu